[Applause]
Sniper Elite games are about perching
yourself in a bombed-out tower pulling a
trigger and watching a bullet careen
through nazi flesh-and-bone these skull
shattering bone destroying kill shots
make the series a devilish joy but where
the series has regularly faltered is in
the moments in between these euphoric
long-range kills
however with Sniper Elite for developer
rebellion has changed all that
Sniper Elite for features expansive
sandbox is brimming with open-ended
objectives that you can choose to
complete in any way you desire and in
any order you please each one is set in
a variety of varied locales stretching
across picturesque Italian landscapes on
the verge of invasion and each one of
its locales is teeming with fascists
just waiting to be extinguished with a
well-placed bullet collectibles and
advantageous sniping positions are
judiciously dotted around each map
encouraging you to explore and find
opportunities pots the macabre
satisfaction of sniping is increased
tenfold when you're able to execute a
pinpoint headshot from as far as 400
meters away of course Sniper Elite
signature x-ray kills return in all
their morbid glory and the series is
grisly ballistics are still second to
none it might sound a bit tasteless but
there's something wonderfully schlocky
about rupturing an enemy scrotum from
200 metres away
[Music]
getting into fruitful sniping positions
isn't the choy once was either there's a
newfound responsiveness to protagonist
Carl fair burns movement that makes it
easier to get around and stay hidden and
there's a decent degree of verticality
each map as you now have the ability to
clamber up specific surfaces jump across
gaps and climb in and out of windows to
navigate with increased freedom if
you're spotted and the bullets start
flying pulling out your thompson and
going toe-to-toe with bloodthirsty
fascists isn't as clunky or as
frustrating as it used to be
while his cover based shooting is merely
competent at best its viability as a
messy plan be for when things go awry is
very much appreciated and since every
objective essentially occupies a pocket
of space on the map you can cause as
much mayhem and destruction as you
please without worrying about enemies
being on high alert for the rest of the
mission the AI in Sniper Elite 4 shows
an improvement over its predecessors
enemies attempt to triangulate your
position based on the sound of gunfire
and officers will command their over
troops to overwhelm you if they have
your location locked down inconsistency
is a common minister and they're not
always the brightest Bunch there were a
number of occasions where I would simply
circle around an area after being
spotted only to find a bundle of enemies
cowering behind cover near my last known
position with all their backs turned it
was easy pickings if you want a harder
challenge from the occasional bungling
enemy the authentic difficulty setting
strips away all of the handy assists and
extends the life of the campaign with a
steep learning curve you'll probably
want to skip all the cutscenes a second
time round though as the plot is
completely forgettable a stereotypical
world will to tell with an unhinged Nazi
villain and a super weapon only a gruff
American hero can stop some surface
level details touch on the Italian
resistance and the Mafia's role in the
war but it never delves deep enough to
be particularly enlightening or engaging
as a story
Luminos it's crucial we find out what
the Nazis are up to in terms of
multiplayer there are petra of game mode
spread across competitive and
cooperative offerings control asks a
team to battle for supremacy over an
ever moving control point disregarding
the sniper rifle in favor of some up
close and personal skirmishes this sits
in stark contrast to the rest of the
competitive modes which are
predominantly marksmen affairs
if you enjoy cautiously moving across
maps with an eye open for the glint of
an enemy scope then there's something
here for you killing a human player from
the opposite side of a map is immensely
satisfying but these moments are few and
far in between it was never enough to
hold my attention for too long
survival fairs much better as up to four
players work together to survive
increasingly challenging waves of
enemies a la horde mode as snipers
distance is the key advantage and is fun
finding an opportune location to seek
shelter and pick off each wave of
progressively difficult Nazis in a
unique twist the supply box are used to
replenish your ammunition also moves to
a different location every few waves
forcing you to get creative with your
trap placement and discover new areas to
camp out in once more or fire tanks and
heavily armoured units rain down upon
you it can get incredibly intense
Sniper Elite 4 feels like a natural
progression for the series as rebellion
continues to refine its systems and put
a greater emphasis on the long-range
shooting it does so well it's dolphin
action mechanics may be simplistic but
they're functional and regularly
enjoyable and the maps with the
impressive scale open-ended objectives
and clever level design coalesce these
disparate systems into a creative and
fulfilling whole there are still some
issues with AI inconsistency a bland
story and some dull competitive
multiplayer but it finally feels like
this series is living up to its
long-standing potential
[Music]
[Music]